Welcome back everyone this is my new black panther
2 video there's been a lot of reports about how
they're handling the movie we just learned a
little bit more about how they're introducing
mutants in the mcu in the miss marvel series
that's going to continue in black panther 2 later
this year and now they're introducing fantastic
four characters in the main 616 universe so this
is mostly going to be about the new 616 main
version of doctor doom because they're adapting
a critical piece of the doomwar story line for the
movie if you're brand new to the channel comic con
is this week they're going to have a major marvel
comic-con panel we're supposed to get the black
panther 2 trailer we're supposed to get a preview
for what if season 2 the new x-men revival series
i'll do videos for everything because that's just
the beginning they're supposed to be revealing
the future the secret wars arc that we're
in the middle of right now all the upcoming
movies maybe some big casting announcements
for some of the upcoming films that we know
are happening but they haven't talked about a lot
recently like the brand new fantastic four movie
also more about them introducing more legit x-men
inside the mcu so be sure to subscribe to get all
those videos there's going to be a lot of really
cool stuff coming this week but the big news is
that black panther 2 is going to be doing part of
the doomwar storyline that involves doctor doom
trying to get his hands on vibranium doomwar is
his seminal arc in the comics where doctor doom
wages this giant war against wakanda to try and
steal its vibranium he winds up speaking with
boss the panther goddess herself who we just saw
in thor 11 thunder she's still alive at the end of
thor love and thunder by the way like they don't
kill her off during that movie it also involved
the core x-men characters like the core team storm
wolverine colossus cyclops even deadpool was part
of the doomwar storyline just because it was that
big of a story but in that storyline doctor doom
basically winds up making himself a new suit of
armor and weaponry made of vibranium now he wants
to use vibranium for a lot of different reasons
one of those is to make himself a really badass
looking suit but during that storyline black
panther wound up stopping him from controlling
all vibranium on the planet by just using a
device to render all vibranium on earth inert
making it essentially useless to doctor doom but
also making it useless to black panther as well
this was also around the time that shuri had taken
the mantle of black panther from t'challa because
it happened right after the dark reigns storyline
where black panther had been injured so badly that
he needed to recuperate but wakanda still needed
a black panther protector so she took the mantle
but what's happening in black panther 2
is that it's mostly a story about namor
versus wakanda and introducing the iron heart
character so you're asking like why is doomwar
so important why is doctor doom so important to
black panther 2 if they're mostly concerned with
naming the new black panther someone taking
the mantle and what's going on with namor
supposedly they're adapting the part of doomwar
for the movie where doctor doom searches the
earth for a source of vibranium to use in his
weapons and armor now vibranium has a billion
different uses now like they had the joke in
avengers age of ultron like ah you can do so
many things with vibranium but the humans just use
it to create a frisbee doctor doom can do a lot of
things with vibranium what they're supposedly
doing is that in the movie a group is using new
technology created by riri williams on the side
while she's at mit also creating her own version
of an iron man mark 1 armor suit like she becomes
iron heart she has her own version of a cave scene
where she creates a version of her own mark
1 suit but eventually probably by the end of
the movie early prediction to make this should
get a more comic book accurate version of her
armor suit but supposedly she creates some
kind of technology that the villains use
to find vibranium on earth and that leads them to
learning about atlantis underwater and that causes
them to discover neymar and that's why he gets
pissed off because of what this separate group
is doing nothing that black panther or wakanda is
doing in the movie but supposedly he asks them for
help and they deny him help and that leads to
name words beef with black panther and wakanda
but as we all suspected namor isn't meant to
be the real main villain of the movie they are
playing it in a very captain america civil war
kind of way where you have two groups fighting at
each other but neither one is really responsible
for setting things up it's always this third party
this mystery person that winds up being the true
cause of all this fighting that they're doing
so in the movie namor is more of an anti-hero
character and they do have a reason for not
ultimately killing him off like keeping him alive
at the end of the movie so they can use them in
future films so if you're comparing this to a
situation like captain america civil war the real
baron zemo in all this is an actual baron zemo
it's the 616 version of doctor doom who's funding
this other team of researchers who were looking
for vibranium and wound up finding atlantis and
namor like will the real slim shady stand up the
real doctor doom behind everything pulling the
strings but that's how they're adapting that part
of the do-more storyline doctor doom searching for
vibranium and it leading to this giant war that
he inadvertently winds up causing even though
he doesn't really care about it like he doesn't
want to cause a war on earth looking for vibranium
but he doesn't care about it either if a bunch
of people need to die in order for mcu-616 docker
doom to get his vibranium he's totally fine with
that but there's this whole main plot with namor
versus wakanda and shuri nikoi trying to protect
riri williams from namor in atlantis who also
blames her for revealing atlantis the rest of
the world in the whole thing with t'challa dying
during the film and then passing the mantle to the
next black panther that's mostly the main story
it's just the idea that doctor doom is behind
all of this pulling all the strings so actual
doctor doom might not physically actually have
a cameo scene like there might just be some kind
of teaser at the end of the movie or some verbal
shout out or post credit scene that reveals that
all their funds were coming from someone called
victor von doom or lotferia or something like that
letting you know that it actually was doctor doom
and it sounds like they'll save some future movie
for actually physically revealing who they cast
as the actor even though there's lots of fan
casting going around right now for the brand
new version of the fantastic four characters
i just did a doctor strange two doctor doom
video because they revealed what was going
on with doctor doom in that universe but it
was the 838 version of doctor doom i'll post
a link to that video in the description below but
there was this huge connection with reed richards
basing his portal technology on doctor doom's
time travel platform and that being connected
to what was happening with king the conqueror in
the multiverse so there were like all these big
connections they were drawing between doctor doom
and all these other big secret war story lines
so it makes sense that the main 616 version of
doctor doom would also be tied with some of that
as well but his storyline will be a little bit
different from 838 universe doctor dooms as far
as mutants in the mcu neymar is known as the first
mutant in the comics that's because he debuted
in the comics before stan lee and jack kirby
actually created the x-men characters in the 60s
even though within the story chronologically there
are older mutants like apocalypse and celine but
they didn't create those and introduce them till
way way later in the movie supposedly they're also
going to say that namor has been a mutant in the
616 universe and he is much much older and spoiler
warning for miss marvel if you haven't seen those
episodes but in the miss marvel series they also
just canonized her as a mutant which the producers
clarified after the finale in your genes like
like a mutation
so if it wasn't clear the producers did say that
miss marvel is supposed to be a mutant in the mcu
they had always planned on making her a mutant
she was never supposed to be an inhuman but it
was all based on this big rights issue and
these requirements that marvel gave them
back when they first introduced the character in
2013 and 2014 in the comics so like the actual
comic book creators always wanted kamala
khan to be a mutant but there was all this
weird behind-the-scenes drama that was going on
and they were forced to make her an inhuman so
when the series came along because marvel got the
rights back to the x-men characters they said oh
you wanted to originally make her a mutant you
can do that now but they also explained that there
were a bunch of deleted scenes with the whole gin
storyline this clandestine dimension storyline so
if it's kind of confusing the way that her powers
work in the way that comron's powers work that's
why there was supposed to be a whole bunch of
scenes and story lines that they had to get rid of
but they said they changed her powers so that
it makes more sense what's happening in captain
marvel 2 the marvel's movie that means that
they're going to be doing a lot more x-men
mutant stuff in captain marvel 2. and now
because of what they're doing with namor
making him a mutant in the mcu like he is in the
comics it sounds like they're going to continue
that storyline during black panther 2. and because
there's this whole subplot with them naming the
next black panther then passing the mantle from
t'challa is supposedly going to separate the idea
like they did in the comics so for a brief period
there was a black panther and a separate ruler of
wakanda supposedly in the mcu now what they're
going to do is embaku is going to take over the
rulership of wakanda and he's just going to be the
brand new king and shuri is just going to become
the next black panther killmonger did burn all
the heart-shaped herbs so supposedly there will
be a story line in the movie where she finds some
kind of a workaround that gives her the powers and
the same ability to commune with the afterlife
the ancestral plane this alternate dimension
there's supposed to be all kinds of twists with
that but basically the idea at the end of the day
is that she will take the mantle of black panther
so whenever they pick up with whatever black
panther three winds up being the third film on
the trilogy she'll start that movie being the new
black panther i'm also assuming because they're
doing a lot of the doomwar story line during black
panther 2 early as part of the subplot is doomwar
they're not going to do that story for black
panther 3 like it'll be some other story when
they get to that movie as for other fantastic four
characters supposedly there's rumors they might
introduce the thing on the she-hulk series and he
might be played by jason siegel but that's just a
rumor right now i don't know if that's gonna wind
up being true we will get she-hulk episodes
really soon i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes so make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss any of those
we'll get a lot more trailers for that really
soon there's been all kinds of casting rumors
for the main 616 version of the fantastic four
so hopefully they'll announce some of those plans
during the big marvel comic-con panel this week
but of course i will do videos for everything
that they announce the new black panther 2 trailer
that they're supposed to release this week will
clarify some of the details about what's happening
in the movie but i don't expect it to answer every
single question it's going to be like marvel's
trailers in the past like they'll try to hide
some of the plot and some of the details i'll
post that video as soon as they release it along
with a bunch of other trailer videos it's going
to be a good week we're going to be eating good
this week everyone click here to learn about
the god of the symbiotes and thor 11 thunder
in a bunch of other deleted scenes and click here
for my brand new black panther 2 namor first look
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!